i like throwing a curveball at the
beginning um if someone has actually
never seen
anything that either of you have done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why
oh that's a good question what's yours
reg i'm curious what's your lead like
what would you want to lead with
oh
you know what i'll leave with what i had
i had because i don't know but maybe
black monday because i loved playing
dawn okay black monday's dope yeah and
it had a mixture i would got to be
comedic and then some good moments with
don okay black black monday i got you
what's yours
i would probably
i would say oj
because like the emmy
i knew he was gonna brag
because he knows i don't have one or a
nomination and he just he threw up the
emmy you see how hard listen
i had there was the there's emmys for
other things but this one
honestly yes
because i feel like oh it means he let
me know he had more than one did you
hear that
no no no no no no no no no no that
honestly that performance was insane so
go ahead i appreciate it because there's
there's things that were fun about it
and then there's things that are very
serious about it i thought it had a nice
range to it so yeah i'd go with that i
know this is a little bit generic and i
apolo i hate the generic question but
what was it about this material that
said i need to be a part of this i want
to do this there was a short that i
watched first that gave me an idea of
the tone that adama and adani were
looking for in the film
then i read the script and the script
actually goes a little bit deeper
obviously than the short does and it
showed that they were looking to
critique the church from a position of
love which i think is a place where real
critique can transpire and hopefully be
sort of contagious like people will be
able to accept it because they're
recognizing that we're not trying to
tear something down but build it up
stronger yeah
yeah and i think you know i had the the
just the opposite um
way in in that i read the script first
and then i saw the short and i think
between the combination of the both of
them and then meeting with um with the
girls what i shouldn't call them girls
but with uh adama and adani the director
and the producer who were and and and a
few other producers who were so smart
and so clear
and you and there was something that was
like you know
i mean the leap of faith like this
because it did it did feel like it could
be really it was going to be good it
felt like a big swing yeah yeah that was
the big swing and so um
but you know who better to swing with
right
what's harder learning lines of dialogue
or the lyrics to nook of your book
you know what i'm going to say dialogue
because anytime you have a rhythm
like it's just like poetry anytime
there's a rhythm in a meter and like a
rhyme scheme or something that comes a
little bit quicker i would say yeah no
what do you think
well you know what i would say when the
when the lingo or words used are
familiar it's a little it's a little
easier for me so
the knuck if you buck like
i wasn't used to speaking but but it was
fun to learn and it was fun to hear the
music and it was fun to play with
sterling
and it was fun for the set you know the
atlanta crew
to be that excited to do it for both of
you you guys really are great in this
and deliver these powerful performances
but sterling specifically you have to
deliver these sermons and really you
know go for it and can you sort of talk
a little bit about for both of you what
was it like preparing for this project
compared to other things you've worked
on and was it a little bit more
challenging or it's just different it
was a little challenging just because of
time constraints you know what i'm
saying when you're working on a film of
a particular budget and with a
particular number of pages
and where two people are doing a lot of
talking like you have to be ready to go
like we shoot nine pages in a day what
not which is not typically what things
are going down so it required a lot of
stamina and just like i had to eat the
right stuff like get enough sleep and
that's something that you have to do all
the time but this one was very condensed
and you have to be mindful of that day
in day out yeah and with the timing
if you don't you don't have it memorized
you can't play no you know what i mean
you can't do deliver the lines but also
stay in character
to
do what come what may you don't you
don't have any room to play so it was it
was it was definitely like go to work go
home memorize more yeah i mean he had
more well if you had plenty no don't
stop please well but you did have some
sermons i had some stuff he had some
sort of truth uh regina i definitely
want to ask you about the praise miming
and standing on the side of the road uh
because
i i couldn't believe it when i was
watching but what was it like for you
yeah i think i think well it was hot i
mean
first and foremost
but i think for trinity it was just it
was the lowest point i think
lee curtis you know i think i think
trinity feels her role in the church
there's a certain
there's a there's a regal quality you
know that she feels in being the first
lady you know it's like being the queen
and
so i think she makes a
reference to being reduced to being a
court jester so i i think for her it was
it was
it was
the point in the in the in their
relationship
um
[Music]
where um
she felt
devalued that she allowed this that
there
there was a level
that she had allowed herself to um
to come or to reach that um
[Music]
it was the beginning of change
it it it was you know when the bottom
falls out when you hit
rock bottom i think it i think it was it
was so it was painful to do there's so
much i mean you didn't drag black jesus
out of the storm she had that ran over
your pinky toe like dance dance on the
side of the road making signs yeah and
now she's like you asked me to like put
on me i saw the love scene so it's not
like he did something to make her
didn't put it on her tonight before so
she would be like you know there was um
she was very nice to put on his makeup
he was very much in service to lead
curtis in service to the church and not
in service to what what
felt good for trinity a lot of times and
that no need to stop i'm just going to
say congrats on the movie um i really do
hope a ton of people watch it thank you
for your time thank you so much thank
you i love your collection yes
i say thank you for that um good luck
with the speed dating